I just wanted to come on and I don't do
this often I don't
like it I'm not good at it I don't like
I'm not good at it and I don't like it
but I just wanted to address your
concerns about my body and talk a little
bit about
what it means to be a person
with a body and to be seen and to be
paid such close attention to I think we
could be I think we should be gentler
and less comfortable commenting on
people's bodies no matter what if you
think you're saying something good or
well-intentioned we should really work
towards not doing that as much there are
ways to compliment someone or to ignore
something that you see that you don't
like that I think we should help each
other work towards just to aim towards
being safer and keeping each other safer
but I just also wanted to say
one
there are many different kinds of
beautiful there are many different ways
to look healthy and beautiful
I know personally for me the body that
you've been comparing my current body to
was the unhealthiest version of my body
I was on a lot of antidepressants and
drinking on them and eating poorly and
at the lowest point of my life when I
looked the way you consider my healthy
but that in fact wasn't my healthy
um and I shouldn't I know I shouldn't
have to explain that but I do feel like
maybe having an openness and some sort
of vulnerability here will be something
like good might come from it I don't
know I don't know but that's the first
thing
healthy can look different the second
thing is you never know what someone is
going through so even if you are coming
from a loving place in a Caring Place
that person probably is working on it or
has a support system that they are
working on it with and
you never know so be gentle with each
other
and with yourselves and thirdly
um
the third one's unrelated I guess I just
wanted to
extend some love your way and tell you
that you're beautiful no matter what
phase you're in
um
by the way I'm not wearing eyelashes or
eyeliner right now this is my face these
are my eyes so don't freak out about
that now too please oh my God but yeah
sending you guys a lot of love
and I think you're beautiful no matter
what you're going through no matter what
weight no matter what
how you like to do your makeup these
days no matter what
cosmetic procedures you've had or not or
anything
um yeah I just think
you're beautiful and
wanted to share some feelings have a
very beautiful day
and I'm sending you a lot of love